while i was someone i wallow supported
like very early and like pushing the
line and i end up giving him a percent
of some [ __ ] because it really changed
my life you feel me helped me and it's
like
things like that wait
okay okay so give me so you gave wallow
a percentage of what
record yeah okay a record okay exactly i
gave him a percentage of a record
because he like really
wallow was one of the reasons like some
[ __ ] really blew
up like everything changed i was getting
a call from every [ __ ] label in the
world that morning and i was like bro
like you deserve a percentage you feel
me if i was with a label they would be
taking hella so you feel me like i had
to it was a
easy call for you know it was a great
he's a great guy being able to break
down the pie and do splits it's like it
allows me to do [ __ ] like that when
[ __ ] really come in and like help me
to just bro you feel me like that's
something long term
in [ __ ] 10 years i feel like i'll be
one of the biggest artists in the world
that percent is gonna be
a real stop do you feel me